all right
very good all right
it's my goodness I'm I'm getting scared
please don't ravage me all right it's
Friday and you know what that means we
filmed the killing of a random audience
member
check under your chairs
I'm kidding that's Monday let's welcome
tonight's guess she's an independent
voter but she knows Kurt loader most of
the Kennedy Saves the World podcast
Kennedy
he brings Florida heat to his
congressional seats Florida Congressman
Byron Donald
she's like a blow dryer full of hot air
and usually in the bathroom Fox News
contributor
and finally Hummers are his roller
skates my massive sidekick in the NWA
World Heavyweight Champion Tyrus
it's out of here not in the coffee
all right
so before we get to some news stories
you know it's Friday so that's when we
do this
Greg's leftovers
hmm yeah it's leftovers where I read the
jokes we didn't use this week and as
always it's my first time reading these
so if they suck don't blame me blame Joe
Mackey
one of our Riders
as you can tell by his pasty countenance
pudgy pale and sad Joe Mackey all right
sorry
wow here we go the White House has
banned a transgender activist for
flashing their breasts during a pride
event President Biden initially had no
comment on the exposed breast as he was
busy restraining hunter from sticking a
dollar bill between them
all right
I know where this is going that is so at
his 46th Birthday Bash Kanye West served
Sushi off the bodies of naked women
worse I'm pretty sure it wasn't kosher
cold wait are you booing uh are you
booing
September anti-semitism
John Hopkins University is under Fire
for redefining lesbians as non-men
which is also code for professors at
John Hopkins
a woman whose remains were found in a
garment bag has been identified after 45
years police remain baffled as the dry
cleaner said she'd be ready by Thursday
funny even though she's dead it's still
funny
that's sad dark it is a Belgian
prankster don't we love them faked his
own funeral before showing up at the
ceremony in a helicopter
where he was greeted by family and
friends who promptly beat him to death
[Applause]
the FDA has approved over-the-counter
sale of the first topical treatment for
erectile dysfunction called eroxon
consumers are encouraged to combine it
with their other product your rocks off
what a weird thing
I guess you'd call that an ointment
topical treatments we used to call them
ointments yeah
ointments such a gross word all right as
San Francisco was squeezed by crime and
other quality of life issues every hotel
or even Hotel owners are starting to
leave in fact downtown is so unsafe many
San franciscans are searching for new
places to defecate
[Laughter]
Pat Sajak is leaving Wheel of Fortune
after more than 40 years when asked for
comment Sajak replied
yeah
this is when I feel sorry for our blind
viewers
very conf very confused right now why
are they applauding serious squinting
yes air quality across New York City was
slightly worse last week as smoke from
Canadian wildfires passed over the city
once again to get a breath of fresh air
New Yorkers actually had to get into a
cab
it's a pre-uber joke
crisis rages on New York is opening two
more emergency centers on the city's
Upper West Side an elementary school is
so overcrowded with migrants
administrators had to cancel this week's
sex toy demonstration
yeah it's sad but it's true what's
what's coming to this world
a man in the UK was busted in a park for
having sex with a tree stump
he said he would have liked to have kept
on going but he was totally sapped
even likes what
whapping
at least he wore a condom so he wouldn't
get a splinter
I guess it gives new meaning to the word
woodpecker
[Applause]
I feel dirty thanks for coming yeah this
weekend this week President Biden had to
undergo a two-day root canal after
reports that he eats like a child
he also walks talks and poops like his
pants like a child
oh too easy too easy Paul McCartney says
the Beatles last record will feature
John Lennon's voice with the help of A.I
meanwhile Yoko Ono is working on a robot
that will destroy the other robot
archaeologists in Spain are expressing
their excitement after unearthing a 500
year old six-inch Stone penis
well they're claiming it's six inches
finally Pizza Hut just debuted a limited
edition pickle pizza it's all part of a
bigger plan to increase sales at
Domino's
all right
let's do
let's do some news
the president with no brain thinks we're
building an ocean train it's true well
Joe came up with an ingenious
Transportation plan this week God I hope
it's our plans to build a railroad from
the Pacific all the way across the
Indian Ocean
we have plans to build a railroad from
the Pacific all the way across the
Indian Ocean I can go on but I'm on I'm
going off script I'm going to get in
trouble
get in trouble once again the President
says out loud that other people are in
charge so a train across the Indian
Ocean what's next an elevator to Narnia
an escalator to Candyland a bean stock
to tyrus's house
you're welcome to come up yeah
meantime you better not ask him about
his family's wheeling and dealing with
Ukraine he'll get testier than
supermodels when they run out of Greg
[Laughter]
thank you
all right roll it
into the FBI appointments
that's such a great question
well someone's doing their best Trump
impression apparently I'm old enough to
remember when that behavior was
considered hateful later in the evening
Biden held a screening of Eva Longoria's
new movie Flamin Hot I was really
disappointed by the misleading title
turns out it's not about Natalie from
Facts of Life
R.I.P
she's still alive I'm just saying the
character doesn't exist
anyway the audience on the White House
lawn featured many Hispanics and to
Joe's dismay they weren't there to mow
the grass
no he's a racist
on the bright side no man flashed his
breasts I wonder if Joe Knows Eva for a
long time
we've known each other a long time she
was 17 I was 40.
I didn't know Eva Longoria was 70.
[Laughter]
then later he went in for a hug that he
held a little too long
yeah
[Applause]
it's probably it's probably payback for
Dr Jill slapping tongues with Doug emoff
but Eva had to physically remove his
liver spotted hands from her taut torso
and it's not his fault he thought she
was an ice cream cone
meanwhile North Carolina focus groups
show sweet voters are concerned by his
Advanced age participants who backbited
in 2020 after supporting Trump said they
feel exhausted and without confidence
whenever they see him Mumble nonsense or
fall on his face but they'd still vote
for him in a trump rematch unless of
course rigor mortis sets in what's Joe
gotta say
no no no look that's fine Ava's a good
sport she just got stuck in the old Joe
pincers that's all if you don't want me
to have a snack don't put a spicy
chicken tender in my face
and I knew about the uh I wasn't gonna
build a train track on the ocean all
right I know the difference between a
boat and a train I just mix them up
because uh a boat goes two dude and a
train goes two two all right
I can mix up a toot toot and a choo choo
all right but just don't mix up a
popcorn and a corn pop
oh you're gonna be saying bye bye Jack
all right
Kennedy
is it possible because I'm hoping this
is true that he spilled the beans on
something really amazing because the
worst story is that he thinks it's
happening but what if we are building a
train across the Indian Ocean that's
kind of awesome I mean that's like going
to the Moon somehow on a balloon or
something yeah that Greg you you
probably bring up the the best point
because that's like some Jets and it is
you know we thought flying cars would be
a big deal but flying floating hovering
trains that's going to change the course
of humanity for the better and we're the
ones who get to do it yeah I know you
know we all think that he's this
daughtering old man but maybe he's an
ingenuitive genius if this this is all
an act wow I said it here first no
wonder those confused voters are going
to vote for him again even though he's
the worst president we've ever seen
ah
[Music]
if you applaud that you're just eating
into my time
Congressman welcome to the show does any
of this really matter any of this
criticism because I mean the Democrats
are going to do what the Democrats do
they're either going to support Joe or
they're working behind the scenes trying
to figure out who's going to replace it
but none of this like the jokes that we
make or anything really really matter
right no the jokes matter okay you got
to do this because it's it's so
ridiculous and so hilarious My Hope Is
that voters are like is this guy really
with us is he really this gone oh I
can't make that decision but to the
train thing that's actually a violation
of the Espionage Act this thing is
happening yeah he leaked information to
the world that is true that's true lock
them up yeah I don't know so cat what up
nothing how you doing how's your water
it's tea Excellence excellent so uh what
do you think's really going on what's
really going you have your finger on the
pulse of politics I sure do yes
um see I I really I do get a little
tired of all of the criticisms always
being about his age and how his age
makes him unfit for the job when really
I think it's more accurate to say that
the things going on with him physically
and mentally make him unfit for any job
like I wouldn't want him helping me at
Zara yeah
number that designates your age this
stuff is concerning like if I were
walking around the office yeah and I was
shaking hands with the air and talking
about being raised by Puerto Ricans I
wouldn't want you guys to be like you
know what she's 34 so she's fine put her
on the air yeah
it's not there's plenty of 80 year olds
who don't act like that right that's
true some of us some of them are still
at Fox
I don't even know who I'm talking about
Tyrus
so I'm drinking Jack yeah it's Friday
[Applause]
what do you think's going on right here
I feel like people are jocking to
replace Joe you had the Gretchen Whitmer
profile you got uh you got Gavin Newsom
everywhere including you even went on
Hannity which is amazing yeah Gavin's
doing the don't make me sing thing don't
make me run yeah don't make me run I
don't want to run okay I'll run
um I think you know it's so it's he's
he's the green President right
so how are you going to build this train
you're going to have to rip up the ocean
floor
kill all the little mermaids and
flippers and stuff and then
according to AOC it's got to be done in
what we got four years left now so we
gotta get yeah and then with the ocean
Rising so our little trains are going to
be in submarines and let's not forget
the
560-day trip is going to be from New
York to India on the train and when you
get the good news is when you get pushed
out you're not going to get run over you
can eat by a shark so that's going for
he is quite possibly the most
incompetent president Congressman
Senator grandfather you name the title
he would be the worst greeter at Walmart
you've ever seen and the Hanson
that where I'm sorry but even the
audience laughing where are the
feminists he just groped a woman yeah
that was not that is a a hands-off
reaction yes it is a lot of oops or
bring it in brother yeah whoa hey Pop
and then kept if there was she almost
ran on a stage yes she did get away from
him and everybody's okay with this yeah
yeah if that had been president Trump
yeah it would have been it would have
been Billboards outside he's like the
grandfather in madman remember that yeah
he started going crazy they put him in
the closet
no he's the grandfather from road trip
ah yes
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else